media under attack journalists face
increasing threats in the field and
online from disinformation and
censorship
so what can be done to protect the free
flow of news and information
this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad jim joom the internet is a
place for the free flow of information
as well as attempts to control and
suppress it this year's u.n world press
freedom day is highlighting threats to
the media especially online
russia's war on ukraine is a major
example
the committee to protect journalists
says at least seven media workers have
died in the field since the invasion
began in february the media has become
the battleground for competing
narratives on the conflict britain's
government has accused russia of running
a so-called troll factory in saint
petersburg to spread disinformation and
lies on the internet and the u.n says
online attacks on journalists and
information are eroding public trust
this year's world press freedom index by
the ngo reporters without borders issued
warnings on how propaganda and
unregulated social media are fueling
divisions within and between countries
examples include russia's propaganda
campaigns before its invasion of ukraine
the united states france and poland the
report says are facing some of the worst
media polarization due to misinformation
and opinion-driven media the civil
society organization forum of
information and democracy wants
countries to adopt legal frameworks and
systems to protect information online
the european union has proposed laws to
limit lawsuits designed to silence
journalists and human rights advocates
they would give courts more power
to dismiss cases if they're found to be
abusive or unjustified
the eu criticized some governments and
businesses for using defamation
proceedings as a form of harassment
the role of journalists and those that
keep power in check is tremendous the
package that we propose today a
directive and a recommendation to member
states
will ensure that they can exercise this
role in some but not all member states
defamation is still a criminal offense
that carries a prison
sentence
member states are therefore encouraged
to abolish prison sentences for
defamation cases they should favor the
use of administrative or civil law
instead of criminal law for such cases
[Music]
all right let's go ahead and bring in
our guests rebecca vincent is director
of operations and campaigns at reporters
without borders she joins us from london
joining us from venezia in ukraine is
romeo kokriatsky he's managing editor at
the new voice of ukraine
also joining us from london is tim
squirrell he is head of communications
and editorial at the institute for
strategic dialogue a very warm welcome
to you all and thanks so much for
joining us today on inside story rebecca
let me start with you today
where does the state of press freedom
worldwide stand right now
unfortunately we've reached another
world press freedom day where the state
of press freedom around the world has
gotten worse
this year
a record total of 28 countries have
dipped into our worst category of the
index indicating that their country's
situation for press freedom is very bad
we've highlighted a number of trends in
the analysis that comes out with our
index uh but the overarching theme of
this year really being that we've
entered a new era of polarization and so
we've looked at um how polarization both
within countries and between countries
has impacted the state of media freedom
around the world and the impact has
indeed been significant
romeo just how difficult and dangerous
are things right now for ukrainian
journalists and also how tough is it to
counter disinformation and propaganda
and to make sure that accurate reporting
is getting out
it's not
i would say that over the past eight
years ukrainians have become
masters of countering russian
disinformation uh the escalation of uh
of propaganda during the war is to be
expected but i think that ukrainians
have
we have developed a media ecosphere that
is very resistant to russian
disinformation and i think now finally
we've been able to start exporting
that kind of resistant ecosphere to the
rest of the world because russian
disinformation is
i think as everyone here knows
incredibly pernicious and has basically
infiltrated um nearly every aspect of of
the modern narratives uh that we have
as for the dangers of reporting i mean
it is a war zone um a lot of cities are
however safe um reporting from levi does
not merely carry the same risks as
reporting from occupied hereson for
example um and for those who are living
in occupied territory um
i mean they are incredibly brave and i
am incredibly grateful for the work that
they're doing um
but
as
these areas uh stay under occupation for
longer
uh
it will only grow more and more
dangerous for the journalists um working
in russian occupied areas and of course
for journalists that go and visit the
front lines um but generally i would say
most journalists are in relatively safe
cities and we for now
have about the same level of security we
did
before the war barring the occasional
missile strike
tim
you heard romeo there talk about the
pernicious effects of russian propaganda
and disinformation i i saw you nodding
along so i want to get your reaction but
also i want to talk to you about the
fact that the british government is now
saying that russian internet trolls
based in saint petersburg are targeting
world leaders online that they're
spreading support for putin's invasion
of ukraine you know initially many had
considered that russia was losing the
information war when it came to
propaganda about ukraine
is that changing at this point
so there's a few things to tease out
here um i don't necessarily share the
same kind of optimism of romeo around
the resilience of the information sphere
outside of ukraine we've certainly seen
no concert attempts from pro kremlin
forces to push their narratives
elsewhere um on social media in
mainstream media in various other spaces
um so for example in the aftermath of
the butcher atrocities when they came
out um i see the study looked at the 200
uh sort of posts which were most shared
across facebook in 20 different
countries and found that while a
minority of them about 55 were disputing
the kind of true account of what
happened in butcher they were more
shared than the other 145 combined and
so there's still quite a lot that social
media platforms and tech companies need
to do to try to clean up the information
ecosystem and make it more resilient to
the kinds of narratives and propaganda
that they're coming out of the kremlin
in terms of your second question around
whether we're whether we or the west are
winning the information war i think it's
a complex picture so obviously around
the beginning of the war you had a lot
of people say
zolensky in particular was doing
extremely well and ukraine um more
broadly um
that was taken as quite a western
oriented view and if you look at some of
the studies coming out of isd and
elsewhere you can see that there are
real inroads being made a lot of
non-anglo-sphere communities um by by
the kremlin so for example um rt in
arabic is doing extremely well um if you
look in a number of other countries you
can see this across the social media
landscape as well so
while
it may be the case within the west
they're doing reasonably well um russia
is attempting to push its narratives and
win the information war on a number of
different fronts and we can't afford to
let our guard down that
romeo let me also ask you about about
what the british government is saying
because they've also alerted
international partners uh that they're
going to work closely with allies and
media platforms in order to undermine
russian information operations from your
perspective
what are the steps that need to be taken
in order
to counter this and and what can be done
to protect the free flow of news and
information
i think one of the biggest tools that
the kind of liberal democratic world has
to counter this different disinformation
specifically on social media is the fact
that social media companies are based in
liberal democracies um they are
accepting of course for the child so uh
chinese social media companies they're
mostly based out of silicon valley um or
somewhere else in the united states and
that means that they must respond to
regulatory pressure they must respond to
policy makers they must respond to
legislation
um
the greatest tool that we have in order
to really ensure that the social media
companies clean up their act that they
stop giving a platform um to obvious
conspiracy mongers um obvious peddlers
of disinformation is to mandate them in
some way and i'm not a policy expert um
don't take that my word is gospel but
there must be a real conversation about
a legislative approach or regulatory
framework that can be applied to these
social media platforms uh that will
somehow
constrain the operation especially of
bots because a lot of this
discrimination is not being shared
organically it is first boosted to an
insane degree um by bot networks and
then once that initial engagement has
been registered by the algorithms only
then is does it begin to get traction
organically and spread from there so
there
has to be something to constrain the
activity of these bots often these are
networks um as we know in russia these
are networks funded and operated by
state actors uh and taking anything less
than a regulatory or legislative
approach to that problem is not going to
fix it you can't rely on the uh tech
companies themselves the social media
platforms themselves to self-regulate
because
first their incentives are not there to
do so and secondly
they are not state actors and they don't
really have the resources necessary to
counter a state working on a
disinformation
direction on their own
rebecca we were speaking before about
the 2022 edition of the reporters
without borders world press freedom
index and one of the issues that that
highlights is what it calls the
disastrous effect of news and
information chaos so i want to ask you
what is the impact of a globalized and
unregulated online information space
that encourages fake news and propaganda
and how bad is it all getting
well that again is one of the major
themes that we highlighted in the index
is the impact of all of this on the
state of press freedom around the world
so when we talk about polarization we
mean exactly that the sort of um the
impact of
disinformation proliferating on social
media but also outright propaganda and
that's not just a matter of um internet
trolling that can be actually done on
official media channels and so
um this year we have seen that within
countries including our own democracy so
i know we're we're mostly talking about
russia at the moment but it's worth
noting that part of the trend is even
within our democracies the proliferation
of opinion media the sort of fox
nusification of media is also
contributing to this chaos and then of
course the propaganda wars of
authoritarian states including russia
against democracies it's all creating a
lot of tension when it comes to to
global press freedom so it's worth
noting that of course while the ukraine
uh conflict was preceded by an
information war this is not a new
phenomenon this has been building for
years when it comes to russia and it's
not only russia we've pointed for a
number of years to concerns with china
for example um reporters thought borders
published a landmark report just in
december uh really examining um
the the spread of china's model of
information control which china is now
trying to proliferate throughout the
region and in fact internationally as
well it's it's not just a russia problem
it's broader than we think um at
reporters without borders we do think
that um there needs to be greater
responsibility of the platforms what
that looks like um it has to be done in
a way that protects press freedom and
freedom of information at the core we've
engaged in advocacy around the european
dsa for example which we think currently
looks like a good model of how this
could be accomplished here in london i'm
watching carefully what the uk
government is doing with the the online
safety bill we've got a few concerns i
have to say
but it's clear that this space does need
some regulation
so tim you heard rebecca there talk
about the fact that these online spaces
uh from her vantage point uh need more
regulation i also heard romeo talk about
that there should be frameworks put in
place to help safeguard information
that's out there i want to ask you you
know there's growing calls for countries
to adopt legal frameworks and systems to
protect information online to to counter
disinformation of course one example
rebecca mentioned the dsa uh um
with the eu but but do you think that
we're going to see more of this is this
trend going to continue are there
countries out there that are going to be
setting up systems or passing
legislation in order to do this
well it's absolutely necessary for these
kinds of regulatory frameworks to be
introduced and i just want to give a
quick word about what they need to look
like as well as the fact that they need
to exist because up until now we've both
relied upon platforms to moderate
themselves and also taken a really
piecemeal approach to content moderation
which looks at specific pieces of
content or types of content and tries to
remove them rather than examining the
underlying business models of the
companies rather than looking at how
their own models and how their own
algorithms can encourage the kinds of
problems that we're seeing so what we
really need is a systemic approach which
allows us for example as researchers to
access data to encourage rigorous levels
of transparency so that we can see just
how big the problems are and how they
are functioning and because all this
data shouldn't be in-house at ten
companies it should be available for
scrutiny um by those who are qualified
to look at it and so we need to make
sure that these regulatory frameworks
enshrine that um in law and i really do
hope that in addition to the dsa in
addition to the online safety bill that
other countries with clout and with
large numbers of users in them start to
adopt these because the power that they
have is directly proportional to how
much of the market of a tech company um
is regulated so the uh the dsa in europe
means much more for example than the
omni safety bill in the uk if the us
weren't to introduce similar kinds of
legislation that would have much more
power still partly because of these
country companies being based primarily
in silicon valley and then i guess if i
may a word about uh tiktok which is a
bit of a problem because of the fact
that it is chinese owned
it doesn't have the same kinds of
regulation or accessibility as nearly
any other platform it's the most opaque
you basically have to do any kind of
research on it manually we have no
conception of the scale of the problem
on there but the manual qualitative
research that we have done shows that
there are huge amounts of propaganda
being pumped onto the platform um from
state actors and non-state actors like
marguerite to simonian um the the editor
of russia today or rt um has an
extremely popular account on there even
with rt and sputnik being banned
it's important to note that this
platform in particular has become a
massive new vector for disinformation
and we really need to do something about
that romeo it looked to me like you were
reacting to some of what tim was saying
did you want to jump in
no i just wanted to to mention that yes
um
as tim said i think
taking this uh individualized approach
to um creating regulatory frameworks for
these uh social media platforms i mean
twitter and facebook don't work alike
tick tock and instagram don't work like
and there is no
one size fits all framework you can
place on all these platforms and say
well the problem solved you do have to
approach them
individually based on how the platform
operates and i think this is an
incredibly
important insight to remember when we
consider kind of what the the future of
digital communication is going to look
like and now that
we have
uh matured enough to to encounter these
massive massive information problems
rebecca so in april the european
commission announced that it wants to
see the eu adopt a law to protect
journalists and civil rights activists
from lawsuits aimed at censoring them
but in order to take effect
this proposal is going to need approval
from eu member countries and from
lawmakers in the european parliament
first and foremost do you think that
this is going to happen and secondly how
significant would it be if it does
you'd have to scrutinize the the bill in
question but in principle of course
there is a need for greater protections
um in particular uh for journalists
online
and
i i don't know if that particular bill
is focused just on the sort of
disinformation side if it possibly might
extend to for example um uh covering
slap strategic lawsuits against public
participation because i know there's
been a lot of advocacy uh towards um
securing protections against slaps uh
particularly that that target
journalists at the eu level um from from
my perspective that would be a positive
thing but again we have to see what is
tabled um and and to assess indeed what
support it has and if that might then be
possible not only at the european level
but possibly replicable elsewhere
rebecca i also want to ask you um from
your vantage point how much better
equipped are our fact-checking
organizations now at dealing with
disinformation whether it's surrounding
the war in ukraine whether it's
surrounding the pandemic other
propaganda efforts just how much better
have fact checkers online gotten at
countering uh propaganda and
disinformation
well from reporters without border side
we haven't actually focused on
fact-checking initiatives because our
press freedom mandate means that we
focus on journalism and frankly if
something has not been fact-checked it
is not professional journalism um we
have worked instead to develop the
journalism trust initiative which is
essentially
a white listing exercise we've developed
a standard initially at the european
level but which we're now working to
roll out more globally that looks to
sort of encourage and incentivize
incentivize um journalism that has gone
through a rigorous chat to show that it
is about professional ethical standards
of journalism so we feel strongly that
it shouldn't be about the content but
about the process because then you
address the content issues that arise
but if you only address content as
fact-checking initiatives do that is
only addressing the symptom and not the
disease
tim the u.n has said that online attacks
on journalists and information are
eroding trust from your vantage point
how bad are things getting
i think that's extremely important to
note because fact-checking is one thing
and so is stopping frivolous or overly
litigious lawsuits but we have to
address the root cause of this which is
at least to some degree that trust in
journalism trust in democratic
institutions trust in electoral
processes
is really being eroded on a systematic
level by a variety of actors
and the demand side of disinformation
isn't being addressed either so it's not
just that people are being supplied
a range of different narratives from a
range of different um bad actors it's
also that
they are looking for that kind of
information because in many ways a lot
of things in the world feel like they're
getting worse people feel like they
can't trust authority authorities
and so consequently they end up going
looking for things which make totalizing
uh conclusions about the world which see
in black and white terms which often
appeal to conspiracy theories um because
those give them more satisfying
explanations than many of the things uh
many of the real mechanisms which
underpin the way the world works and so
that's deeply problematic and and we
know that the many of regimes and also
many governments are in and and
political parties in states are engaging
in these sorts of campaigns to undermine
trust we saw it during the trump years
in the us we see it with russia right
now we see it with for example north
african regimes like the eritrean regime
we see it in eastern europe it with
hungary or central rio rather
and that's deeply problematic so i think
we are in a really quite dire state
right now with respect to the amount of
trust that we place in journalists and
the amount of attacks that happen um in
the online space as well as offline as
well as the sort of prosecutions and
other kinds of lawsuits
romeo do you think we're at a moment
where we'll see a drive by more members
of the international community to
actually strengthen protections for
journalists and for journalism
unfortunately um i can't
really say that i'm optimistic
uh in this sense
there has been a consistent trend over
the past few years
in basically the opposite direction
there has been um a huge movement which
uh
is based around the
kind of concept of free speech or at
least that's the rhetoric that they use
and you saw some of this with um when
billionaire elon musk uh said he was
going to buy twitter and bring free
speech back
but that rhetoric actually serves to
obscure
uh the actual
practical effects of what these
so-called free speech policies would
bring which would be an end to
moderation or incredibly hands-off
moderation which in turn will only uh
intensify attacks and densify dog piling
intensify smears and further erode trust
in any kind of institution including
journalistic ones so
unless governments really
take a
long-term and
uh
kind of layered or nuanced look
situation instead of simply bowing to
the rhetoric oh we need more free speech
we need less regulation uh they're
controlling your speech unless that kind
of rhetoric is ignored and um the
question is probed further by
policymakers
then i don't see that situation
improving especially when it has
um such you know wide support from uh
very influential individuals in the
public sphere rebecca how much uh have
surveillance and hacking compromised uh
journalists of late and and not just
journalists but also
their sources and and whistleblowers how
much dangerous has how much more
dangerous has it gotten for them all
it is certainly increased um i think
tensions it sometimes can lead to
self-censorship if if somebody feels
very um
ill at ease in investigating for example
certain risky topics or individuals um
it's also worth mentioning the impact
immediately that all of this has on the
safety of journalists um in parallel to
trolling this act of sort of abuse and
threats and these you know vast pylons
that can happen very easily towards
journalists and in particular um often
disproportionately targeting women
journalists uh too often now can
translate into real-life manifestation
of such threats and sometimes violent
acts and so in our broader work in the
sort of more classic areas of press
freedom such as safety of journalists is
also having a massive impact as well um
it's all part of the evolving nature of
threats to journalism and certainly
states are not uh doing enough at least
in a concrete way beyond just statements
we need to see more action including by
our democracies uh to ensure that um
their their own house is in order with
the domestic press freedom climate and
that includes um ensuring that the
online space uh is a safe and enabling
environment for journalists to be able
to do their jobs
all right well we have run out of time
so we're going to have to leave the
conversation there today thanks so much
to all of our guests rebecca vincent
romeo kokriatsky and tim squirrel
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story
how much i'm doing the whole team here
in doha bye for now
[Music]
you